the planet I'm Shanon McWeeny I'm the
division head for bio infinite come to
show biology dr. Hirsh is away and so
I'm going to do the introductions in his
absence it's my pleasure today to
introduce Melissa on she's going to be
presenting work for her master's thesis
proposal some important things to
remember this is a great opportunity for
our students to present their research
ideas and get input if you ask questions
we ask that you remember that we're
recording and this is being streamed so
just hold the button down so that the
question actually gets captured when you
ask the question keep it held down if
you're watching this on the web and you
have questions you would like us to ask
her you can tweet them if you use the
hashtag de maiz Conte conf X you can
barely hear me de maiz conf or tweet it
to OHS you informatics I'll be
monitoring that and we can ask her at
the end melissa is in a program that's a
partnership with Portland State
University in which the students start
off on kind of an accelerated bachelor's
in computer science and then come here
to finish so it's basically like a very
expedited three-year bachelor's program
and then come here for their final two
years for the Masters in biomedical
informatics and with that most of the
floor is yours
thank you so can everybody hear me okay
okay all right so today my talk is
implementation of the hot net to network
diffusion based analysis method and
reactances so an overview of today's
talk will be an introduction to networks
the hot net two algorithm current
implementations and my specific aims for
this project
so high throughput experiments produce a
lot of complex datasets these datasets
are readily available to the public but
this data often contains only partial
omics information and it's often very
noisy and contains a lot of false
positives or negatives so a big issue we
have is how can we process extract and
explain the data to better understand
diseases and biological processes so a
popular method is to combine biological
data with networks and then extract and
explain patterns in biology so this has
already been been done in predicting
protein function comprehending chemical
reactions and organisms and detecting
relationships between diseases
computational tools are able to do these
things because networks can be
represented in the form of an adjacency
matrix
so using these matrices computational
tools can analyze data detect patterns
and integrate additional biological data
to understand why it's important to use
networks nowadays I'm gonna provide a
little bit of background on how
interpreting biological data has changed
so in the past we take a complex data
system and break it down into smaller
simpler basic individual components to
study so one gene for one disease and
although this was beneficial in the past
most studies now they show that some
diseases are caused by multiple mutated
genes so now we're more focused on a
holistic approach where we study
multiple components within and between
complex systems of James proteins cells
organs and organisms an example is where
we inspect multiple mutated genes for a
single disease how those multiple
mutated genes might be related to each
other and the possibility that they
might also impact other diseases so this
provides us with assistance perspectives
and using networks we can integrate
different
rules of information to help us better
understand biological systems and
diseases so in regards to disease
studies we can map these diseases onto a
protein protein interaction Network
which is shown in grey on the screen so
the circles are nodes and these
represent proteins or genes and the
lines are edges these represent
functional and/or physical relationships
between genes so if we're interested in
studying the relationship between two
different diseases shown in green and
purple we can map these diseases as a
group or module onto the network so as
you can see there's two genes that both
have green and purple and that just
means that those genes overlap in both
disease a-and in disease B so
furthermore networks can also be used as
models to apply concepts and algorithms
to biology so a concept I'll be talking
about it's heat diffusion so if you have
a source of heat that heat can disperse
into the surroundings that are cooler so
to illustrate this when we're given a
network with a hot central node before
diffusion that heat will stay in the
same place but as the fusion occurs that
heat in the middle will slowly spread
out and heat up the surroundings cooler
neighbors and so this is what will
happen so this concept of heat diffusion
we can apply it into biology so here's
an example this is a keg pathway map and
specifically it shows the J and K and
p38 kinase pathway it's involved with
cellular functions such as proliferation
differentiation inflammation and
apoptosis so if J and K were to become
mutated it will block the upstream
signals from the genes shown in pink and
that will impact the downstream signal
to the genes shown in blue
and this will cause cellular function
changes and it will also affect the p53
signaling pathway and so this just goes
to show that when one gene gets mutated
it can affect multiple genes throughout
the network and by using diffusion it's
possible to model this functional impact
of how genes will impact each other
across a biological network so to use
this idea of diffusion we can combine it
with Network data and gene scores to
observe how the individual genes will
influence each other in a network so the
network represents how genes are related
to each other physically and are
functionally and gene scores are a list
of genes where each gene is assigned a
significance value based on the study of
interest so an example is for disease
studies one of the main goals is to find
key candidate disease genes and the
networks we commonly use is the human
human human protein protein interaction
Network and the gene scores are a list
of genes each assigned a significant
score based on their potential
involvement in the disease and that
significance score can be based on
p-values or rankings from previous
studies so going into a bit more detail
about the gene scores so the gene score
significance can be converted into the
heat score for heat diffusion model so
the more significant a gene is when it's
converted it will have a higher
temperature when converted into heat and
so this enables us to use specific gene
information and combine it with the
network data and in biology we already
know that genes will impact one another
so if we're given genes of varying
significance level in the form of gene
scores and we can place that onto the
network as a model and we can get a
better understanding of how significant
disease associated genes will affect or
influence other genes because the
significant genes will diffuse their
scores into the surrounding
neighbors and so this approach of using
gene scores and networks is known as the
diffusion based approach an algorithm
that uses the network diffusion based
approach is hot net to and so there are
four steps in hot net two and I'll go
over each of these steps in detail next
so in step 1 we use diffusion to
estimate how genes impact each other so
to determine how all genes will impact
one another hot net 2 uses a diffusion
process known as insulated heat
diffusion that means that in the process
of diffusing heat from neighbors
neighbor each of the nodes will retain
some of its own heat and this is
determined by the beta parameter which
represents a fraction of the heat
retained so in this example each node
will retain half of the T and that means
the remaining half will be shared
equally among its neighbors and so given
a pair of genes a and B we're going to
determine how he is transferred so from
A to B a only has one neighbor so a will
retain half the heat and the remaining
half will be transferred into B and from
B to a node C has five neighbors so node
B will retain half the heat and the
remaining half is shared equally among
those five neighbors and so the gene to
gene relationship from A to B it's half
the heat it will get transferred and
from B to a only 1/10 the thinking it
gets transferred and then this step is
repeated for all genes within the
network so we can get an impact
estimation of how all genes will impact
one another and once we have an
estimation then we need to determine the
actual impact genes will have on each
other
so to do this we combine the results we
obtained in step one where we estimated
how much heat was transferred with Gene
scores and these gene scores are as a
reminder their significant scores so
these significant scores are then placed
onto the network like so so for
a 0.01 and 4b the significance score is
0.02
and then with perform matrix
multiplication by multiplying the gene
scores with the estimated impact for all
genes and then so the actual amount of
heat transfer from A to B estimated it
was half the in reality it will be 0.005
and from B to a estimated was 1/10 that
actually it will be zero point zero zero
two so based on the actual amount of
heat exchanged we will now have a
network containing information about the
significance of each individual gene and
the amount of heat that is exchanged
between all the gene pairs in the
network so using this it brings us to
step 3 where we can obtain sub networks
by removing gene relationships below a
threshold so to illustrate this let's
look at the legend I have on the screen
for heat transfer so the red arrow means
that high amounts of here transferred
between those and the white arrow
represent less than not if he is
transferred so in order to subtract
these sub networks we need to set up
threshold to remove gene to gene
relationship so if we set the threshold
below that orange arrow it will filter
out the yellow and white heat transfer
arrows from the network here's an
example after filtering as you can see
based on that threshold only the red and
orange heat transfer arrows are left and
the yellow and white arrows have been
removed so after that threshold we can
group the remaining nodes into sub
networks like so and after this we move
to the final step where we determine if
these sub networks are significant or
not so in the final step of hotnet we
determine the significance of the sub
networks by evaluating the p-value and
getting the false discovery rate
so this means that for all possible
subnetwork sizes p-values are obtained
based on the number of sub networks for
a given size in the actual network and
it's compared against the randomly form
networks so continuing the previous
example and the previous example will
obtain this actual data table and so
this means that for a sub network of
size five nodes you see that there's one
sub network that circles and for a sub
Network size of green nodes there's also
one sub network that is circled and then
in the network we create the random
networks by using the same notes so with
different edges we rerun hotnet too and
then we will create a similar table to
this and by doing so we can compare the
sub networks in the actual data with sub
networks in the randomized data to get
that p-value which will indicate how
significant sub networks look for
certain size or greater our and then
from what those p-values we can
calculate the false discovery rate and
so the next slide I'm going to
demonstrate how to get those pvalue in
case my on the description was a bit
confusing so continuing from the
previous example we have the actual data
set and then for the random data sets
you either perform hundreds or thousands
of permutations and for the sake of this
example I'm only showing two of the
hundred possible random data sets so in
the actual data set we can set a
threshold to be three sub three nodes
and then we need to also set that same
threshold in the randomized data set and
then then we can plot the distribution
and get that p-value to test how
significant sub Network size is greater
than or equal to three nodes are so
using p-values we can then calculate the
false discovery rate for the sub
networks that we find and by completing
these four steps hotnet to it
able to integrate network data and
individual gene information to find sub
networks that are potentially involved
in diseases so from the liaison at all
2015 study they're the ones that made
came up with this hot net two algorithm
they were able to detect the Sui Smith
conflicts and this is a known important
tumor suppressor sub Network and so this
is what it looks like and if we want to
check the frequency of mutated genes and
patient tumors because their gene scores
are based on the frequency of mutations
in patient tumors so we want to map this
sub Network back to see something
important when we map that that into
that frequency scene the hot genes are
the ones that are highly mutated and
they are also possible known
cancer-causing genes and the rarely
mutated genes are the colder ones and
they're considered insignificant so as
we can see in that significant sub
Network it includes one of the blue
jeans a DMP and that means it has a low
frequency of mutating in patient tumors
and so this stuff network just shows
that frequently mutated genes and rarely
mutated genes when you combine them
together they can actually play a role
in cancer and are important so using
hotnet two sub networks of known
mutations can be expanded to include
interacting genes and proteins that
might also be associated with cancer
that are usually ignored because
statistical testing them as
insignificant and so for those
interested in using Hartnett two there
is a current implementation available in
Python but you need command line
software scripts to run it and it's also
very time consuming and because you have
to use these command line scripts it's
probably difficult and unintuitive for
biologists or clinicians without pro
and to the best of my knowledge there's
known software that provides a graphical
user interface for network visualization
analysis of the whole hot net to
diffusion algorithm workflow to users so
to make content to more intuitive I'm
going to implement it in society escape
we have Thomson's app so cytoscape is
one of the most popular biological
network analysis and visualization tools
it's a platform that's Java based and it
has about 150 apps that can assist in
network analysis and reactances is one
of those many apps so reactances
performs network visualization analysis
using the reactive functional
interaction network of biological
pathways and it contains about 60% of
the total human genes so I chose
reactances because it has already
implemented a previous version of
continent 2 so this means that my
project I can use that previous
implementation as a framework to build
upon and I can focus on optimizing
hotnet 2 and providing users and
intuitive network visualization actually
so because reactances and cytoscape are
jaar jaar birthdays my project I'll
implement hotnet 2 in Java and based on
the results on the screen we expect that
there will be performance gains so to
solve issues related to making continent
2 more intuitive and optimized for
visual analysis I propose the following
objective so I want to implement hotnet
2 into reactances a cytoscape app and
for the first time provide biologists
and clinicians a tool to analyze their
own data using this powerful diffusion
based algorithm and they can also use
this algorithm alongside other
pre-existing network and pathway
features using a suite of rich graphical
user interfaces to accomplish this
objective I propose the following
specific aim
so in aim one I will port hotnet to from
Python into Java and the method I used
is this
so I'll implement hotnet 2 into Java and
compare the results with the Python
implementation to ensure that my results
are correct and assessment will be based
on accuracy performance time and memory
consumption so by following this
procedure the finalized version of code
will be correct robust efficient and
usable for future integration into
reactances to assist with code
assessment I'll use the visual VM
profiling tool that's provided by Java
and this just tracks performance and
memory usage to inform programmers which
methods they should improve upon so for
performance information that provides
you a picture and information on the
next method execution time and the
number of implications that are made so
this just provides insight to me on
which functions I should probably focus
on and optimize to decrease the
execution time and the number of
treatments of method calls and for
memory usage it can be a City test
unnecessary memory usage memory leaks
and bottlenecks so by understanding
where and how memory is used throughout
the development process code can be
better optimized to handle large data
sets and prevent issues from occurring
so since hotnet 2 uses the human
interactome it's a very large data set
and it also needs to perform hundreds to
thousands of random permutations to get
the results so it's very ideal that my
code is able to perform quickly and
accurately so it's very essential that I
track and make sure I'm using the
correct data structures and my functions
are correctly implemented because this
will assist in minimizing performance
time and minimize memory consumption so
once the code is optimized I'll begin
aim to where we integrate hot net to
into reactances as the GUI based
intuitive network analysis tool and
evaluate the usability among researchers
the approach used is first I'll
integrate Java version of hot net 2 into
reactances using the previous version as
guidance and then after integration I
will modify and add visualization
features related to the input format
network visualization and parameter
selection and then finally ru usability
test will be conducted to ensure that
these features actually do assist and
analyzing data so here's a workflow of
what the user will be able to do through
the workflow so the input they can
provide a mutation annotation file or
gene scores and while comment 2 is
running they'll be able to view the
progress to see how much time is left
before the job is completed and the
results presented to the user will be a
list of significant sub networks and
visualized sub networks so for network
visualization the user can view the
notes colored according to their
significance so hot means most
significant and cold means we
significant and this just provides user
details on specific individual genes
within the network or they can choose to
view the network in the form of coloured
sub networks and so it's expected that
the GUI workflow and the network
visualization features will enable
researchers to analyze significant sub
networks more easily so to ensure that
these expectations of mine are met
reactances with this hot net 2 algorithm
and these new features will be provided
to users for user testing users can use
their own data or provide sample data or
use the provided sample data set and
prior to testing
I'll only provide users the reactant viz
tutorial from reactant org and that's
just to get them familiar
with the pre-existing reactances
features the tutorial does not contain
any information on how to use Hartnett 2
so following testing the users will be
asked to fill out a systems usability
scale questionnaire to assess the
partner 2 and the visualization features
are useful or not questions include ease
of access issues with usage and
appearance and also get additional user
feedback to improve the hotnet -
integrations before my project is
complete so in the usability testing
questionnaire participants are asked to
score 10 questions on a scale from 1 to
5 one is strongly disagree and by the
strongly agree score will be added and
then it will be ranked based on the
percentile to determine if the usability
features were helpful or not so upon
completion of specific aims to users
will be able to easily analyze data
using reactants this is implementation
of hotnet 2 with new GUI features so in
conclusion the proposed project will
expand reactances by incorporating
hotnet 2 as an interactive network
diffusion based analysis features for
biologists and clinicians the
user-friendly software will with this
optimized algorithm will accelerate
disease gene analyses to benefit
biologists and clinicians with and
without programming experience and users
can also take advantage of cytoscape
once about 150 apps to further enhance
their analyses for further research and
so I was like - and with by
acknowledging dr. Lu as being my advisor
thanking dr. McWeeny and dr. Romo for
being my committee members and I'd also
like to thank to be my staff in
particular this Diane and miss Lin I'd
also like to thank my family and my
friends in the gay scene in Utah for it
I know I have some extra time so before
I go into questions I just want to
describe the previous version of hot
knit 2 in case you guys were wondering
so the previous version of hot knit 2 is
called hot net and there's issues
because it's very biased towards these
star-shaped clusters like the one you
see on the screen so that middle node
will be very hot and it'll be surrounded
by a lot of cold nodes and so to
overcome this issue hot net 2 was
developed and uses a different type of
heat diffusion so in hot net because
heat diffusion where all the heat in
onenote is transferred to the other and
then hot net to use insulated heat
diffusion so each node retains part of
the heat and the remaining half is
shared hotness ignores the direction of
heat traveled so from A to B it will
choose the least amount of heat that
gets transferred and record it for both
then hotnet - it records the heat
separately so from A to B it will have
its own score and from B to a it will
have its own heat transfer as well so to
illustrate this for the hot net input if
we give it a star-shaped poster you can
see how for hot net it doesn't have
those arrows giving heat directionality
and so the output will be that star
shaped cluster is that in hot net - it
includes directionality and so the cold
jeans will be removed because only the
hot center node is there another example
it's not the star shaped poster anymore
but we can see how hot net it doesn't
remove any of the old jeans and hot net
- because of W and s there's heat
transferring between both of them that's
more significant than just the hot as
snow transferring minimal heat to the
changing thank you and any questions
it's about your evaluation where are you
gonna get your subjects and do you need
an IRB protocol yes I do need irony so
I'm working on that right now you're
gonna use this subject so where are you
gonna how are you going to recruit your
subjects for this think about professors
in the department and they're not
available because it's probably really
busy even people from the BCB cohort I
don't know maybe if there's a way to get
like you know the hot net user community
and recruit people from that wider scope
that would be you know less I don't to
say bias but less less well known to you
so maybe more more optimal think about
that a little bit though because if you
have people who are very familiar with
there's two pieces that you might end up
evaluating and I look to your questions
you have to think about this one would
be are they evaluating how easy it is to
use the implementation they know hotness
and then air is deafening about this
more and more and then Erin's dead-on
but your pictures for biologists and
like clinicians that you : who wouldn't
necessarily be experts in the hot net
and if that's the case it's actually a
different evaluation and so it's really
important to think about that because
then you wouldn't many people in the
department may not be familiar with this
analysis and especially from the
clinical faculty I would argue that's
probably true but you probably would
like to get some of the same from the
biology sites from the some of the
biology departments but you do need to
think about that because like the
question you had up on there Melissa if
they're saying how we do the system well
it could be super easy to run it but if
I don't understand the algorithm so you
want to make sure that your questions
differentiate between that or that your
user base does yeah so you know there's
a couple of user bases and a couple
kinds of questions you could
at this you could look at this as you
know the current implementation versus
the old for users that are familiar with
this and what's the difference or the
improvement or you could look at people
that are not familiar with using it but
would be interested in using it and
would have data that they would find
useful to apply to this and just you
know didn't know though how would they
how did they find using this and then
you just just write use the system
usability scale but certainly you'd want
to pick a set of users that that you
think would in their normal work benefit
from this even if they're unaware of it
right now I have a couple questions
about porting the Python code over to
Java
so are there packages that are used by
well they the paper for holodeck 2 is
very nice and they have like an
algorithm for it and so I'm kind of just
following the matrix multiplication
using Java libraries instead of numpy
for what the Python implementation is
since there was like a random component
you know there's a bunch of permutations
of their way to generate the same random
numbers between Python and Java so you
can check that you're getting all right
yeah there's a parameter you set when
you're running the program and so I'm
not sure if it'll be the same networks
that I can definitely feed my program
these networks to ensure that they're
the same is that what you're asking
he's getting it is it yeah so the
depending on how they implemented the
randomization and the way that they're
using the seed you'll you'll see they'll
be stutter will be variation
they need to think about in your
implementation is that if it thinks of
all the parameters of the same in this
heated scene because yeah in the last
one I have is if they release updates
for hot net to they find some bug in
their code like updating this as well
kind of
that is there a particular way that side
escape add-ons are distributed and
maintained and made open-source have
been made part of the community or is it
just that there's sort of a collection
of projects some of them live on github
and some of them of some place Alice is
there yeah is there a formal way to to
make this part of the cytoscape
environment yes so set escape it's just
a platform and you just easily click and
install these plugins so these apps
whatever you're interested in you just
easily click click and then it's
installed and you can use it getting in
how its managed that's how you use your
way that you're contributing to yeah we
have it hub to the App Store so
somebody's gonna have to own and manage
this over the long term or it's gonna
become not available to users it sounds
like sounds like if there it sounds like
there's a you could put it on github but
then you'd have to build up a developer
community that was always the latest
into the store or so one thing to
remember what she touched on in the
beginning is that she's developing into
a plugin that already exists in this
maintained by another group which is
react on say so so she's making a module
for that I think it's really important
for Student Center and faculty to think
about that if you do it on your own all
of it rests with you
but if you're contributing into a larger
project you can't
a somewhat general question building off
of that was how do you retain
intellectual property in a setting like
this and still make it make it available
and shared and they have open source
that's algorithm and it's on github and
so I'm just taking what they have done
putting it in a new setting that's
easier and more intuitive to use and so
people that use cytoscape and are
interested they can just move the
reactants is out I think it's question
is so in this case everything you're
doing is open source the algorithm was
open source there's no original art I
think the question would be how do you
communicate and this is a bigger
question than maybe you but it's a good
question how do you contribute when it
is your algorithm so that other people
can use it so that it can be
incorporated and still retain the idea
take a stab at it but that's a big
question I'm not sure but I wouldn't
assume that I have to get a paper
published on it with like results and
then show people like this is my
algorithm these are the results and like
it's actually useful and then so I have
my name kind of associated with that
other than but then it's still available
for people to use kind of thing know
what he's getting at though is that the
publication is still separate than an
electrical property so it's just it is
something to think about and I know half
of those postdocs were in a meeting we
discussed this the transfer and they had
a symposium but it's a really important
point that you need to consider
especially for a nob
yeah thanks Shannon I'm really I do
believe that that the open source and
shared policies that we're moving
towards compared to where we were many
years ago in many areas this is great
it's also important to consider that the
work that you're going to be doing in
your careers and I'll look around the
whole room you're you're going to be
developing processes that it will be
important for your careers over time to
make sure that you retain certain rights
at the same time and to think about that
and to learn about that process over the
next couple years during your your
academic training you ever and this is
right this is like an unanswered
question and like you know having played
with a previous version of Hodnett
you thought about how to integrate
multiple data types like just like for
example including mutation and
expression like in an analysis for
hotness I haven't but I know there is an
algorithm like it has it'll incorporate
mutation information and gene expression
information and so that's called the
tie-dye algorithm so the one the one
thing that like really kind of occurred
to me is that like like a real a real
opportunity here and this is probably
might be beyond your the scope of your
your your current work but it's
definitely kind of thinking about like
giving people the big picture of like
the integrated data because like you
know not only do you like it
the expression of important but like
also epigenomics and mutations and copy
number analysis so if you could kind of
figure out a way to kind of include all
of that data and get people a
big-picture view of how that interacts
it would be really powerful but you
still wouldn't get the